the things that that i have seen
consistently be effective is
carbohydrate loading um i do sometimes
wonder if we're just correcting
depletion rather than
actually super compensating and filling
out um so
and actually the dimarea study made me
go oh maybe maybe it is more than that
because you know five grams per kilogram
um during peak week is not a low
carbohydrate intake and it is quite
higher than probably what most of them
were dieting on but given that the uh
the nine gram per kg group
did look better and had you know
increases in muscle thickness maybe
there was something to it
so i have seen success with
individualized carbohydrate loading
strategies
this is one of the reasons why i like
refeeds and diet breaks it gives you the
opportunity to play with what is our new
maintenance and how much can we push
carbohydrates up and then you can look
at the time course in response to a
refeed to see when someone looks their
best
and people generally fall in a couple
different categories you see people who
just linearly look better as they have
like let's say they have two refeed days
in a row you know halfway through day
one they're looking a little bit better
you know at night they're looking even
better in the morning a little they're a
little bit worse because they've gone
eight hours without eating and then they
start to look even better again
throughout the rest of that day and then
the day after they maintain that look
and then the day after that they start
to fade
but you see other people who kind of
look a little softer during that process
like they're they are maybe retaining
additional water but they're also
filling out uh and there's kind of a lag
and they might look their best to say
the day after the refeeds
and there's other people who
um maybe weren't that depleted in the
first place or maybe don't need to load
that aggressively and just simply kind
of going toward a maintenance look
better so people operate on a spectrum
and it's probably relevant so probably
relative to their body mass their diet
and just how depleted they had to get to
get lean so i think an individualized
carbohydrate loading strategy that is
um you know timed in such a way that you
avoid that quote unquote like bad load
look but also hits them at the point
when they're still looking separated and
then i have actually had success and
this is anecdotal so i don't think it
means a whole heck of a lot with
if anything
loading sodium not if like huge but like
a gram or two uh in the final days and
day of competition
as it seems to correct some of those low
blood blood pressure issues and seems to
enhance not in everyone their ability to
get a pump and therefore their
appearance
but i don't try to manipulate
electrolytes much if anything i try to
keep them relatively constant and i'm
loading carbohydrate and i'm roughly
keeping water the same as well
and the big caveat greg is that
i do start to
practice this in advance if someone's on
schedule for getting lean you know let's
say they're six to eight weeks out from
their first show
it's a great opportunity to
change the refeed schedule such that it
mimics what you're planning to do for
the uh the carb load and it should be
informed by by prior refeeds and then
you can tweak and adjust
leading up to it and the only thing you
really stand to lose is that if you're
manipulating sodium to some degree if
you're manipulating food choices it can
mess with your weigh-ins a little bit
but hopefully at that point when you're
68 weeks out you're primarily relying on
visual data anyway rather than the scale